with the claimed roles in deliverance
and smoking the bandit Burt Reynolds
swagger and charm made him a huge star
in the 70s but despite his box-office
clout and sex symbol status the once
great star seems to have faded away so
why are we seeing more from Burt
Reynolds becoming a star Reynolds began
his career in the late 50s and worked
steadily in small TV roles through the
60s including an episode of The Twilight
Zone playing a cocky actor who gets
punched in the face by a time-traveling
Shakespeare what have I got against this
person itch Stanislavsky you but in 1972
deliverance gave Reynolds his first
major movie role however just before the
film was released Reynolds was invited
to pose nude for cosmopolitan it was the
first nude male centerfold in the major
magazine and he figured people would
look at it and laugh and forget about it
a few days later but instead of being a
laugh riot
it made Reynolds a sex symbol of the 70s
it also diminished his serious acting
accomplishments and deliverance was very
oven very stupid it did not change my
career to the better Reynolds had become
a huge star but he was never really
taken seriously which would haunt him
for the rest of his career a few bad
choices Reynolds signature stash and
cocky smile won over male and female
fans alike through the 70s but by the
80s his movies were already getting less
critical acclaim 1980 ones that can
involve run featured an all-star cast
and made a lot of money but critics
weren't pleased also released in 1981
with the well reviewed drama Sharky's
machine which had Reynolds as its star
but he squandered those critical games
by following that up with best little
whorehouse in Texas the forgettable best
friends and the horribly reviewed
stroker ace
by the time 1984 rolled around Reynolds
return for Cannonball Run 2 which got
even worse reviews and made 44 million
dollars less than the original by
sticking to a run of mediocre comedies
Reynolds wasn't being taken seriously
and he could only charm audiences for so
long and if the first half of the 80s
seemed troublesome for Reynold the
second half only got worse Reynolds work
included a cameo in the bizarre smoking
the Bandit Part 3 and the terribly
reviewed run a cop things didn't get any
better from there too many refusals over
the years Reynold turned down a lot of
roles that would wind up becoming iconic
in an interview with Business Insider
Reynolds revealed that he could
played the first American James Bond but
he felt double-oh-seven was a role only
an Englishman can play and before
Harrison Ford took a break from
carpentry to play a han Solo Reynolds
was reportedly offered the role in the
early 1980s the male lead in terms of
endearment was written especially for
Reynolds but the star said no as he'd
already committed to stroker ace the
role into Jack Nicholson and Reynolds
regretted his decision even today then
in 1990 Reynolds reportedly turned down
the starring role and pretty woman due
to the age gap between himself and Julia
Roberts while these choices didn't
affect his career at the time they
definitely hurt his legacy instead
Reynolds retreated to TV starting in
sitcoms for much of the late 80s and
early 90s appearing as a disembodied
voice an out-of-this-world and an
ex-football star an evening shade he
even won is first and only Emmy for his
performance in evening shade
unfortunately after four seasons the
show went off the air and Reynolds went
back to making bad movies until 1997
aborted come back in 1997 Reynolds got
the comeback role of a lifetime and no
it wasn't in the mr. bean movie but I
love my country I can't stand the idea
of a bunch of French cheese owning
America's greatest paintings what's
beyond muggy nights was the film that
made Paul Thomas Anderson a famous
director to watch and a role in the film
gave Reynolds the claim that he hadn't
seen in a long time
but despite overwhelming critical praise
Reynolds didn't really go anywhere after
playing Jack Horner
so why didn't Boogie Nights work for
Reynolds like pulp fiction did for John
Travolta well first of all Reynolds
didn't actually like Boogie Nights right
oppa told the Guardian that even though
he's never seen the movie all the way
through he still hates it and that
working on it was a nightmare
mostly citing creative differences with
Anderson's still Reynolds rage also
extended to the cast and according to
his book but enough about me Reynolds
almost gotten a fistfight with co-star
Thomas Jane though the shoot was
difficult Anderson had no complaints
about Reynolds performance even offered
him a role in his next film Magnolia but
Reynolds turned it down saying I'd done
my picture with Paul Thomas Anderson
that was enough for me personal problems
in addition to a spotty film career
things were also pretty difficult in
Reynolds personal life after marrying
actress Loni Anderson in 1988 the couple
divorced in 1993 it was not amicable and
Reynolds called the marriage quote a
really dumb move while Anderson lobbed
accusations of abuse when the smoke
cleared Reynolds agreed to pay Anderson
a little under $250,000 though
we didn't complete the transaction right
away it's a 22 years for Reynolds to
completed payments in 1996 the actor
filed for bankruptcy but was able to
keep his large ranch in Florida which he
eventually sold anyhow by 2014 money was
still a problem so we held an auction of
some of his personal belongings
including props costumes and awards from
his films however other items he tried
to sell seemed a little more desperate
like his voided credit card he's still
busy despite these bumps in the road
Reynolds is still working just not
always on the big screen right through
those who else could keep this town
running in addition to popping up in a
few voice roles he created the Burt
Reynolds Institute in acting studio in
Florida where aspiring stars can learn
from Reynolds himself even now at over
80 years old Reynolds recently completed
the film dog years and has multiple
films set for release in the new future
for a guy who's been in the business for
six decades that's incredibly impressive
Reynolds star may not shine as bright
today as it did 40 years ago but he's
still an icon who will always have a
place in film history and a few bedroom
walls thanks for watching click the blue
Pro icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]
[Applause]
you